so very famous philosopher from Canada
once said I got enemies got a lot of
enemies got a lot of people trying to
drain me of this energy I don't know if
you've heard of this philosophers name
is Drake yes right and the whole purpose
about this message today is ten enemies
of success that you have as an
entrepreneur that's holding you back
we're gonna talk about that today before
I get into the episode if this is your
first time visiting this channel this is
the number one channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs we got over a thousand
videos for you to watch a lot of weird a
lot of strange a lot of get interviews
click on subscribe button and go watch
some of the other videos that we have
after watching today's episode having
said that let me get right into it 10
enemies of success you have as an
entrepreneur point number one judging a
business based on a great year a lot of
times people say Pat were blowing up did
you see what we did last year show me
our numbers well in 2014 we did five
hundred thousand dollars then we went to
a million then million won then we
dropped a little bit but we went up last
year and we went up to four million
dollars we're absolutely killing it so
on the outside everything looks good
then you open up the engine you start
looking at the numbers it's one big sale
or it's one big customer it's one big
account that made them spike up so I've
experienced this with my business by the
way this also applied to a BAM EUR or a
great you can you know judge your
business based on one bad you're one
great cure my rule is very simple if you
grew a hundred percent this year and you
do that three years in a row of 100
percent then you have a legitimate
business if you grew by a hundred
percent this year next year is 10
percent the following year is five
percent you never did 100 percent it's
the rule of three if you do a number
three years in a row it becomes real
point number two building your business
based on quick fix campaigns rather than
strong principles there are a lot of
businesses that like we got a new sale
going on we got a sale going on we got a
sale going on it's always built on a
sale this product is normally nineteen
thousand nine ninety nine but in the
next five minutes just for you because
we like you even though we've never met
you before only $99 take after credit
card five minutes for fifty nine
fifty-eight sign up today and then you
go to another website you come back it's
the same exact five minutes four fifty
nine it works with certain people but
that's not a real business to build on
that's not a real philosophy to build on
I suggest building on real business
philosophies which we'll get to you here
in a minute that builds you real
business regardless of a sale regardless
of a market crash regardless of a
recession regardless any of that stuff
because you have the right philosophies
in place we'll get to you in a minute
point number three flattery nothing's
worse than everybody telling you how
amazing you are and you believe in yet
oh my gosh you're so amazing oh my gosh
you're a great CEO oh my gosh you're
doing great stuff I have a very simple
philosophy when it comes down to
flattery if it's not my wife who knows
all my flaws she's seen me in my worst
places if it isn't the people that I've
been working with for years who know
everything about us if it isn't the
people in my immediate family whom I
trust the compliments generally comes
from this year leaves here when you guys
say pad you're so amazing it goes boom
boom boom boom boom boom
why because you don't know every aspect
of my business of my life
but if my board says I can't believe
what's happened with the business pad
the last decision we made that was great
and I think you took the right lead on
it
that's compliment that you should take
everybody telling you this then what
happens you go home like this honey why
do you talk to me like this do you know
how everybody looks at me do you realize
Who I am why do you talk to me like this
because flattery fooled you into
thinking you're God and you are not God
so flattery hurts all the other
relationships around you if you let it
get to your head number four isolation
you're growing and you're typically
around everybody then then your office
gets further and further and further and
further away from everybody then you no
longer come and shake hands and talk to
people then there is a wall your
customers your employees your
salespeople your vendors your partners
they no longer talk to your isolated
you're on an island of your because
you're so important you're so incredible
and then all of a sudden you are
irrelevant because no one knows who you
are and I know a lot of books out there
a lot of books out there that tell you
well you should do this you should
disappear as you do that I say it all
the time but I don't tell you to
disappear from your employees from your
customers from your vendors from your
partners
gonna disappear from people disappear
from your critics disappear from your
haters disappeared from your prior
friends or family members that said
you'll never make it then show up five
years later saying Merry Christmas
here's Patrick with every 6.0 here's you
6.0 this is what what's happened in my
life without you saying anything
everybody already knows what you'll be
doing what you've been doing but in a
business world isolation can hurt you
traumatic enemy if you isolate yourself
from everybody
number five perfection you got
perfection you got magic I work with a
lot of people today we're talking about
a new leadership principle we're going
to be teaching to a certain group of our
guys that they're gonna go take this
course there's four different types of
leaders when it comes on to coaching
there's doers there's talkers there's
controllers and their supporters right
doers talkers controller supporters okay
perfection controllers typically want so
much control of everybody everything
because no one can do it as good as them
you know what those that are controllers
do there's so much about perfection that
no one around them becomes leaders
because no one around them can ever be
as good as you because they never give
up too much everything has to be perfect
everything has to be flawless you don't
see a lot of leaders being around them
sometimes if your controller you know
your personality you've got to kind of
start empowering and not seeking
perfection just progress seeing you guys
getting any better and in all of someone
that you look around so my gosh look at
amount of leaders that we built here
business has grown companies growing
perfection as an enemy next not
upgrading your philosophy sometimes
you're going and you're building your
business and you think you're doing good
but your numbers actually don't look
that good but you don't you don't want
to sit down and look at the results of
your philosophy because it's gonna make
you upset so when you sit back then this
was 2013 for me
we had a year in our business I sat
there in 2013 then I sat there in 2014
one of the metrics I was only looking at
the metrics that was positive the one
metric I didn't want to look at was the
most important metric and that one
wasn't good it was flat okay guys look
over here you know one day I'm like Pat
when you're gonna start being really
honest with yourself as a leader man
this this is not it's not growing the
way you think it is growing this
an important data then I put that on the
table it oh my gosh we're gonna talk
about that yes the following your this
data grew one hundred fifty two hundred
percent why because we finally inspected
it because when I'm putting the product
from here and it's going through the
assembly line the final product that's
coming through is not a great product
it's an average product it's a mediocre
product but because I'm too afraid of
upgrading my philosophy and looking at
it I stayed the same and my business
never exposed in order to exponentially
grow and have a lot of success for
yourself you need to constantly work on
upgrading your success and setting aside
your ego because results always tells
the truth
seven spouse and family you're a
business you're doing great
you come home you and your wife you
don't talk about the business you're not
doing good you guys are fighting
everything is in shambles but it's okay
I'm still gonna kill it on business
that's not how it works here's why if I
my business okay I got three kids saying
I don't get my wife and we have we're
not a good place and it's terrible we
don't talk to each other I sleep on one
or she sleeps on another marriage this
happens and I come back to work the next
day my mind it's not a hundred percent
focused it's seventy eight percent so if
your mind if my mind is seventy eight
percent and you're at ninety nine
percent you're not thinking about your
personal life because you got that stuff
under control you have an edge over me
because my brain is less focused than
yours so your brain your brain is more
focused you make better decisions you're
better with people you're easier to deal
with people are willing to tell you some
areas I need to improve as a company
because you're willing to take it at
seventy-eight percent you're quick
you're short views and people like oh my
gosh I don't want to talk to them and so
they leave me on for a week two weeks
and then all of a sudden a small problem
becomes a bigger problem if this is an
issue you got to do whatever you can go
read books on parenting go read books on
marriage go read books on personal life
go read books on everything I talked to
somebody the other day they were in
their mid 50s
watch this here this is gonna sound
strange to you they're not on my company
they're outside they come we talk
husband and wife are sitting there and
it's a pat we simply want to talk to you
because we need some counsel on growing
our business I said before we talk about
the business how you guys doing oh we
don't need to talk about that we were
strictly here for business and I said I
get it but how are you guys doing
it's Pat
it's not that important listen I'm gonna
ask you one more time how are you guys
doing then all of a sudden he says why
don't you go so no you go no no you go
you know what finally happened let me
tell you how weird this was okay but
I've experienced hundreds of meetings I
honestly thousands of meetings like this
when I'm sitting with people in these
kinds of cases
she says to me Pat we haven't had sex
for six months I said how long six
months I said six months yes why not
well it's just you know it's just we
can't get along anymore I said are you
having a hard time with it
no no no that's not the problem we're
just not having sex at all I said what
do you realize one of the most
healthiest thing you can do for your
marriage is to have sex it's like all
the medicine drinking green juice or
tofu and all this nonsense
none of that comes close to us good sex
is for marriage husband wife having sex
it's the best Tylenol the best advil the
best pain reliever the best Prozac the
best whatever medicine you're taking is
you and your wife ever sex and so we
start talking about it why not and so
the real truth came out I'm not gonna
tell you what it was it's a little bit
awkward but we addressed it you know
what happened three months later every
possible record in their business they
broke and they went six months without
sex mid 50s late 50s he didn't have a
pretty he didn't need like your viagra
shoe just that we're not having sex they
did it they sat down both egos they
scored it away then it grew and it
exploded not by a little bit it went
like this so once we address this then
we talked about business and everything
started getting better number eight
compromising non-negotiables for
short-term gain when I'm starting my
business initially a big bank came up to
me and they were telling me Pat if you
introduce this product none of your
people need to know on the side we'll
pay you $100,000 a month okay I said
what do you mean he says they don't need
to know we're doing this for you but on
the side we'll pay you $100,000 a month
and I said look it's just not part of my
principles he says but you mean to tell
me you retain 1.2 million dollars you're
saying no to 1.2 million dollars have
just been given to you
no one's gonna ever know we're giving it
to you per year a hundred thousand
dollars per month
- listen here's what you got to realize
the biggest thing for me if you do
business with me is my principles that
are non-negotiable
I did it with certain things I said I'm
not gonna get married unless of these
three things I've said compromise I'm
not doing it
friendship Business Association air
investment everything has three
non-negotiables I did a video on this
couple weeks ago then the guy says
you're seriously gonna say no the other
guy said yes the other guy said yes this
guy said yes I said that's the
difference they're trying to make a
million dollars you're not trying to
make a million dollars here this is
America there's no limit on how much
money you can make anybody can make
money in America if a million dollars a
lot that I gave talking to the wrong guy
because this guy's not driven by just a
million dollars oh ha ha ha look at this
Patrick why do you talk such a big
language I say I'll let you know in 10
years they left we exploded the other
guys are out of business because they
chase a commission on the set everybody
find out nobody trusted him anymore
why short-term gain you will be tempted
many many times don't compromise your
non-negotiables number 9 poor health you
don't take care of your health what
happens it affects you here it affects
stamina it affects everything help is
very very critical myself anybody I've
seen anyone I work with if there's ever
been a certain level of losing momentum
it's had to do with this and we're aging
certain things you don't have any
control over but it's very critical for
you to pay attention to because there is
enemy of success has to do with health
you can you can no longer just say oh
it's not a big deal it's just cheesecake
I'm just 280 pounds not a big deal
people a lot of people become rich and
they're overweight and all the subs of
all of those are lame excuses pay
attention to there's a lot Spinelli's
speaking the same language to everybody
I don't speak to my seven-year-old the
same way I speak to my five-year-old the
same way I speak to my three-year-old
it's all different languages I speak a
different language to my nanny than to
my wife tend to my father then to my
employees then to my directors then to
my executives that's my vice presidents
then to carriers then to investors then
to my board then to enemies then to
media then to family then to friends
then to strangers all the languages it's
not the same language that this doesn't
mean that I'm a different person here
then I am here and I'm acting all the
time no the language is a different
language maybe in this language is a
technical language I'm going to
my technical language to a higher level
because everybody in that room stock in
technical language maybe in this
community I'm talking to the lower level
I'm gonna speak at this language maybe
in this over here is more relationship
you're talking you know things that
matter to them it's not necessarily
we're talking to a community that wants
to know about numbers I'm talking to
relation today I just did a big
conversation with somebody it's it's
gonna be a massive massive deal I'm not
talking a five million dollar deal
it's a massive deal I'm talking to these
guys and the conversation went from
husband to wife to all of a sudden we
went a complete different direction you
know and the conversation was you know
they're based out of West Coast big
business people complete different
direction we went on the conversation
what happened all of a sudden we talked
personal life not here's how much
business with you this is what we scale
this is what it is if you speak the same
language to every audience you're gonna
lose people
so it's an enemy when you feel like you
can talk to your employees your sales
your executive your investors all the
same you have to take a moment back and
say who's my audience boom let me pivot
and adjust this is the language I speak
to them okay and you don't tell your
three-year-old to learn calculus
formulas are precalculus you know
someone I'm saying that's the
adjustments basic but sometimes we all
forget about it what is the language I
need to speak in this meeting that about
what do they want
perfect here's what we're doing okay so
those are 10 enemies not obviously
there's a lot more enemies these are 10
of the enemies that's gonna be an enemy
of success for you as an entrepreneur
having said that there's another video I
want you to watch I made this video I
want to say a year and a half ago 2018
April of 2018 I think I made this video
the title is how to make a million
dollar income and it's a very detailed
not one of these rah-rah videos I'm not
asking you to pay five thousand dollars
for this video I'm giving you a very
basic formula here's a thumbnail click
on this video go watch it it's a formula
how for you to make seven figures in
today's economy and again any thoughts
comment below if you haven't subscribed
please do so take everybody
you